les vacanciers du littoral atlantique
n'ont décidément pas de chance ils
doivent donc seulement se méfier des
méduses mais aussi slalomer entre les
algues qui infestent actuellement la
plupart des côtes bretonnes et
vendéennes patrick esther si vous
fréquentez les plages de bretagne vous
les avez forcément remarqué cenap
l'algue verte ont particulièrement
proliférer cette année dans les régions
de lannion saint-brieuc saint-malo
dinard et au sud jusqu'au croisic et la
rochelle principal responsable de cette
invasion la pollution créée par l'homme
ces algues se développent grâce au seul
nutritifs contenus dans les eaux usées
rejetées en mer
ces plaques d'algues vertes qui
s'échouent sur le littoral pour east au
soleil en dégageant des odeurs
pestilentielles des odeurs absolument
inoffensive mais si désagréable que les
municipalités sont obligés de les faire
ramasser opération qui revient cher et
pèse lourd sur le budget de certaines
communes possédant de grandes longueurs
de rivage de plus ce ramassage n'est pas
efficace à 100% verte qui tendent et des
plages il faut aussi la stabiliser parce
que si on les stocke cunego en décharge
ou en carrière elle continue à se
liquéfier se dégradent pourri
et puis les jus résultants sont
ce également connu en outre la
stabiliser et si l'enfer des amendements
faire du gaz affaire d'être à rennes
pour les votations du mal tout ça tout
ça est possible autre solution étudiée
dans ce laboratoire des côtes-du-nord
empêcher la formation des algues mieux
vaut prévenir que guérir
d'autant que d'année en année la masse
de plaques vertes a ramassé multiplié
par 2 ou 3 1 table